we've captured a video of some of our
teams doing final integration prep work
in advance of today's test flight
just like Falcon 9 Starship has two
stages which we will talk a little bit
more about in a minute but in addition
to those two stages Starship actually
has a third stage called stage zero it
consists of all the launch pad
infrastructure built around the rocket
you can see a great view of it there on
your screen it's truly an engineering
feat in its own right and I feel like
it's something we don't talk about very
often there's a lot of infrastructure
that goes into fueling and preparing the
launch vehicle before and a large test
like this really any launch
now let's talk about super heavy the
name says it all it's super it's heavy
it's super heavy it goes by some other
names the first stage or the booster but
whatever you call it the super heavy
will be the vehicle responsible for
powering Starship against that Mighty
gravitational pull we've got here on
Earth and when it's fully operational
it's going to get Starship to orbit
the booster alone stands about 70 meters
tall and is about the same height as a
fully integrated Falcon 9 but with a
diameter roughly 2.5 times that of
Falcon 9 and with 33 much larger engines
yeah and having those engines and oh my
gosh I love this shot but you can see uh
looking up into the launch Mount at the
33 engines on the booster those are each
of the Raptor engines that's going to
power today's launch attack yeah this is
an incredible view one of my favorite
views that we're going to get today we
don't have this kind of view on our
Falcon 9 launches so
um this is so exciting to see you can
even make out uh the paint markers
indicating which engine is which like we
said there are 33 of them so
um there's a lot of fire that's going to
be coming out from uh those engines and
just uh over 31 minutes from now as we
mentioned before uh there are 33 of them
on the on the super heavy the booster uh
and the we don't see it right now but
the cluster in this in the center are
the ones that are actually going to
Gimbal and help steer the booster back
down for its water landing in the Gulf
yeah and they're a little bit different
Kate than our Falcon engines um so on
Falcon we use a gas generator cycle
here's a fantastic shot actually at the
the inner stage so we can see the six
engines that are on the ship side three
gimbaling in the middle and then the the
vacuum engines you can see two of them
and the other ones on the other side of
the cluster in the middle here so
Raptor's a little bit different it uses
something called stage combustion which
means we basically pre-burn both the uh
the fuel side and the oxide and then get
those up to the right temperatures and
pressures and then mix them in the
combustion chamber it allows us to get
higher thrust and higher efficiency on
these engines than on falcon 9.
now super heavy also has four grid fins
to assist with orienting itself during
the return back to Earth as today is the
fully uh integrated slice test and the
first one we're focusing on safely
testing just the fundamental systems and
operations on the vehicle so what that
means is we won't be attempting to land
on land today instead super heavy is
going to be making that hard water
landing in the Gulf
Starship or the spacecraft is the second
stage and makes up the top portion of
the vehicle it's designed for carrying
passengers and cargo between
destinations on Earth Earth orbit and
planetary destinations
it stands 50 meters tall a little taller
than the Statue of Liberty it's
comprised of six Raptors we saw those
just moments ago three of them are
optimized for sea level and the other
three are vacuum engines
um and like they're optimized to operate
in the vacuum of space they provide a
maximum of 258 000 tons of thrust in
vacuum
the spacecraft is also outfitted with
four flaps to help aerodynamically
control the vehicle's attitude during
atmospheric flight and enable precise
landing at the intended location you can
see a view of those flaps there
now you can see the in the entire stack
is vertical and that's because Starship
is designed for vertical takeoff in the
landing as opposed to taking off and
Landing like an airplane and that's
really important because we don't have
runways on the moon and Mars fortunately
gravity at both of those destinations is
not nearly as high as it is here on
Earth on Mars it's about a third of what
Earth's gravity is but on the moon the
gravity is just a sixth of what it is
here so Starship can take off in both of
those cases without needing the super
heavy booster like we need here on Earth
now for today's test Starship does not
have its Landing legs attached that's
because we aren't going to be attempting
to return to the launch side or land on
land it's going to be doing another hard
water landing at the end of today's test
we can't wait
Starship is wrapped in a heat shield
which is composed of 18 000 hexagonal
ceramic tiles designed to insulate the
vehicle during atmospheric entry where
temperatures can be as high as 2 600
degrees Fahrenheit the hex shaped tiles
like these ones that we have here
roughly make up about two-thirds of the
vehicle there's a couple of different
geometries the one that I have is for
the circular portions of the vehicle so
it has this this curvature to it and the
one that Shiva has yeah this uh this
kind is a hexagon hexagonal shape and
there's several thousand of these all
across the body of the vehicle and it's
worth saying we need these because when
a spacecraft re-enters from orbital
velocity it's going faster than the
speed of sound and and causes a lot of
heat to build up uh that has to get
dissipated by these heat shield tiles
yeah one the thing that's really cool
about these is they're they're super
lightweight even just holding them we're
able to even just like hear how how
hollow they are because of the
construction and but they do a great job
of dispersing that heat during that
atmospheric re-entry it we actually
produce these in-house at what we like
to call the SpaceX bakeries and they're
located in Texas and Florida so it's
something that we designed and and build
in-house and uh like we said there's
thousands of them uh there uh you can
kind of see them on the exterior of the
of the vehicle so at this point in time
we are at T minus 27 minutes and 18
seconds so let's head on over to John
insprecker for an update on the
countdown hey John thanks Kate and good
morning I'm John insprecker principal
integration engineer here at SpaceX
we're currently loading propellant from
the ground system into both the first
and second stages
now both vehicles use the same two
propellants our fuel is liquid methane
at a temperature of just over 100
kelvins or about minus 272 degrees
Fahrenheit now this is a different fuel
from Falcon 9 where we use rp1 kerosene
and our oxidizer is liquid oxygen the
same as Falcon 9 but because there's no
oxygen in space to support combustion we
have to bring our own
a little bit of a recap we did the gono
gopal at T minus one hour and 45 minutes
and once the team gave their goes we
pulled about 20 folks we started loading
propellants onto the booster at T minus
one hour and 39 minutes and a T minus
one hour and 22 minutes we began
propellant loading of the ship the
second stage on Starship
now locks loading of the second stage
main tank is almost complete right now
but will actually stretch it out and
wrap it up and finish at T minus five
minutes
and then at T minus three minutes is the
booster finishes loading the vehicle
will be fully loaded with just over 10
million pounds per pound
now currently in the countdown we've
just passed the T-minus 26 minute mark
the good news is weather's looking good
you can see the blue skies there on the
camera views from the Drone
the only thing we're watching is wins
they are within limits the ground level
uh we expect they may pick up a little
bit as we get farther into the window
should we need to go that far but the
good news right now is that the weather
is looking good the range also is
looking pretty good we've moved almost
all the boats out of the keep out Zone
overnight we are working one but we're
still underway and right now is a
reminder if for any reason we do not
make our test flight today we have
backup launch Windows this could be the
24 48 hours after today and it'll depend
on how far we get into the countdown but
coming up on 25 minutes to go everything
is looking good okay
in order to make life multi-planetary we
need a fully reusable vehicle that's
capable of carrying a huge amount of
cargo and a lot of people to orbit and
have a pretty quick turnaround the idea
is to effectively reuse launch Vehicles
just like airplanes
crowd is getting excited here in
Hawthorne behind mission control as you
can hear now imagine if you had to wait
for a new airplane to be constructed
every time you wanted to fly you rarely
go anywhere and it would probably be
completely unaffordable for most of us
in order for us to get to Mars and back
with lots of people multiple times
reusability is a must
now in the near term and a bit closer to
home here on Earth Starship will be
critical to other programs as well once
it's operational Starship will deliver
the full size and upgraded version of
our starlink satellites and that's super
exciting because our next Generation
satellites represent a step forward
installing capabilities and will provide
more bandwidth and increased reliability
to connect millions of people around the
world with high-speed internet
and of course Starship will fly a number
of humans-based flight missions in the
lead-up to our first missions to Mars
entrepreneur and pilot Jared isaacman
will command the first human space
flight on Starship as part of the
Polaris program Jared served as a
commander for inspiration 4 the first
all civilian mission to orbit
inspiration 4 launched aboard our Dragon
spacecraft and Falcon 9 in September
2021 raising over 240 million dollars
for Saint Jude Children's Research
Hospital the first human space flight on
Starship will launch as part of the
Polaris program and you can learn more
about that series of Missions at
polarisprogram.com
now our first lunar Mission uh around
the Moon aboard Starship will be led by
Japanese entrepreneur yusaku maizawa
also known as MZ MZ flew to space for
the first time in December 2021
purchasing and he purchased all of the
seats aboard starship's first lunar
mission in order to give artists and
creators from all over the world the
opportunity to go and the hope is that
what they will create in space will
further inspire all of us here back on
planet Earth now over a million people
applied for this Mission and earlier
this year they announced the final eight
crew members were selected and you can
learn more about them and mz's Mission
at dearmoon.earth
Dennis and Akiko Tito are the first two
crew members announced to fly on
starship's second commercial space
flight around the moon this will be
Dennis's second mission to space after
becoming the first commercial astronaut
to visit the International Space Station
in 2001 and Akiko will be among the
first women to fly around the Moon on a
Starship the Tito's that joined the
mission to contribute to spacex's
long-term goal to advance human space
flight and help make life
multi-planetary
SpaceX is also incredibly honored to be
part of NASA's Artemis program to
establish a sustainable presence on the
moon to prepare for Missions to Mars
Starships really test launches followed
by those regular starlink deployment
missions and propellant transfer
demonstrations are directly advancing
NASA's Artemis program along with
spacex's ongoing mission to make life
multi-planetary SpaceX will conduct an
uncrewed demonstration Mission To The
Moon prior to the Artemis 3 mission
which will Mark Humanity's first return
to the lunar surface in more than 50
years it's an exciting future but let's
talk a little about how we got to today
now Starship testing ramped up in July
of 2019 with the star Hopper prototype
it's sort of a short version of the
Starship that we see today there's a
picture of it on your screen The Lovable
water tower now standing at just over 18
meters tall the star Hopper had a single
engine and was test flown to perform
landing and low level altitude Maneuvers
starship's initial flight test was a hop
that reached about 20 meters in altitude
this was followed by a second hop the
one that we've got on our screen that
Rose to 150 meters in altitude we took a
little jaunt away from the launch pad
and ended up Landing about 100 meters or
so further away from it and you can see
that on your screen now notably this was
the first time that we had used a raptor
engine in flight and demonstrated
control of this kind as a Star Wars fan
I can't not see a flying R2D2 there now
after a series of 150 meter hop tests
with earlier prototypes the Starship
program saw a huge breakthrough during a
test flight of the vehicle known as
serial number eight or sn8 sn8
demonstrated a first of its Cod
controlled aerodynamic descent and
Landing flip maneuver yes I'm talking
about the belly flop this 12.5 kilometer
hop test took place December 2020 and
saw the sn8 Prototype Ascend to an
altitude of 12 and a half kilometers and
conduct a belly flop maneuver while it
didn't stick The Landing the test was a
major milestone in the development of
Starship I love seeing the ballet flop
maneuver now testing continued with the
Prototype on serial number nine that was
a 10 kilometer flight test in February
of 2021 we had a nominal Ascent engine
cutoff reorientation and controlled
descent were stable however we
unfortunately had a dramatic ending to
the end of flight when we had a failure
on its engine to relight that resulted
in one of those rapid unscheduled
disassemblies but what was really really
exciting about both serial numbers eight
and nine is how quickly we were able to
achieve just our primary objectives in
those two high altitude test flights in
attention to getting lots of great data
Starship successfully demonstrated
control of the vehicle and subsonic
re-entry capability
ultimately we performed nine Starship
high altitude tests flights in total and
in May of 2021 sn15 launched from
Starbase reached an altitude of about 10
kilometers performed a number of
Maneuvers and safely returned to the
launch site this was the first Starship
prototype to fly control its descent
safely land and to be recovered in one
piece
now it's like having achieved that
success in our suborbital campaign one
of the next big challenges for upper
stage reusability is to survive the high
heating Hypersonic phase of Entry
combined with the ability to refill our
starship's tank with fuel and oxygen
while on orbit is what will enable a
fully reusable transportation system
that's designed to carry both crew and
cargo on these long duration inner
planetary flights and that's ultimately
what will help Humanity return to the
moon and travel to Mars and Beyond in
our solar system
so as you can tell it is nothing but an
iterative process and to get to the
point that we are today and where we
will go from here that iteration is a
core process of how we work here at
SpaceX we like to fly uh and we like to
test early and often both on the side of
hardware and software yeah that's an
awesome Point Kate now we are continuing
our countdown to Starship liftoff just
over 17 minutes from now so of course
let's check in with John for another
status update John
clock is coming up on T minus 17 minutes
from liftoff we're continuing to click
towards zero however right now we've
just begun listening in the first stage
team is working a pressurization issue
they're troubleshooting that right now
we do have the opt-in if need be if we
can't solve this then we would hold the
count and probably treat today as a wet
dress and not be able to watch
however we are continuing to do
propellant loading on both the super
heavy and the ship stages
now most recently we began loading
liquid oxygen and methane fuel into the
header tanks on Starship at the very top
just underneath the nose there there are
two small spherical tanks that's where
the fuel and liquid oxygen header tanks
are
that started at T minus 27 minutes and
that propellant loading will continue
until T minus nine minutes
we'll also continue loading the main
tanks of the Starship second stage
although they're pretty much full right
now everything will drain back as we get
ready for launch of T minus five minutes
now on the first stage we're continuing
to load the massive amount of propellant
onto the super heavy booster that's
going to continue until T minus three
minutes you can see the frost line on
some of the views as both liquid methane
and liquid oxygen go into the tank
it's 16 minutes and Counting we're also
currently configuring the launch pad for
liftoff the booster hold Downs are being
prepared for the release at liftoff and
the second stage quick disconnect is
beginning its configuration for release
the liquid oxygen and methane that are
going into the second stage go through
that quick disconnect you can see it in
some of the views the arm that comes out
just to the base of the second stage and
it'll move out of the way as we lift off
the same time the SpaceX team continues
to check in with the Coast Guard we're
working one boat that's in the safety
perimeter they are working to get that
boat out of the way we cleared several
hours several other boats out overnight
we're down to one and we expect that'll
be clear so that we can proceed with
launch out over the Gulf of Mexico but
as a reminder T minus 15 minutes 10
seconds and counting we are working an
issue on the first stage and we'll bring
an update as we get more insight into
that issue
now today's test flight is taking place
out of our star-based facility in south
Texas and that facility has gone through
a tremendous amount of change and growth
in a really short period of time
yeah I mean three years ago not much
even existed there
um it was a very different scene as you
can uh See by that photo there on your
screen fast forward to today and the
team is building out an entire
production line yeah last year they
built four Starship super heavy boosters
five Starships our 200 Raptor 2 engine
and this year they're targeting the five
boosters eight stars and eight Starships
in production for 2023 and really you do
need a production system to rapidly
iterate like we were talking about
earlier on the design of the vehicle as
we learn more about it from these large
tests yeah absolutely
um pulling on my industrial engineering
background system fill is something that
is critical to that goal being able to
produce and launch multiple Starships
means that we have to have a system full
of those production vehicles and we
iterate on each one so even the next
Starship that will fly and whatever the
next test is will be different than the
one that you see there on your screen
now
now the employees who have been at
SpaceX a while say that Starbase does
remind them of the early Falcon one days
except moving a whole lot faster
the team at Star base is expanding as
fast as the facilities are and if you've
ever wondered what life at Starbase is
like here's a quick peek
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
directly employs more than 1 800
employees and is actually the largest
employer in the area yeah and from that
video you can really tell like it's a
beautiful location it's close to the
ocean there's tons of Wildlife and
that's because being close to the
equator is actually a fantastic way to
get to orbit yeah I love that we have so
many employee events that allow us to
participate with ocean cleanup and other
environmental efforts uh there we'd also
like to thank Cameron County for being
so supportive for all of our work in
that area now in addition to Starbase
we'll soon be adding another Texas
location to the SpaceX family
we're opening a new facility in Bastrop
Texas just outside of Austin to support
starlink Hardware production the new
facility will be over 500 000 square
feet of manufacturing space and the team
has already started hiring now we have
all kinds of openings in production and
Manufacturing for technicians and
Leadership and Manufacturing engineers
and all kinds of site support roles
basically if you can think of a role
we're probably hiring for it so if
you're interested in helping expand
human life to other planets or helping
internet access here on Earth consider
becoming part of the SpaceX team at
spacex.com careers now with that let's
track big back in with Zach down at
Starbase one last time before launch
howdy Zach
hello Kate and Shiva again you can
really feel the energy here at South
Padre Island as more of the SpaceX team
have gathered uh we're standing just
over five miles away from the launch
Mount and so from here we've got a very
nice nice view
um I I would basically say these are
some of the best front row seats you
could get and might I add Beachside as
well now the Starship team has worked
incredibly hard to get ready for this
test and we're all clearly excited for
t0 and as we get into the final moments
one issue that could hold the countdown
or cancel the test altogether is if a
boat enters the safety perimeter now
over my shoulder is the Gulf of Mexico
which is normal normally normally very
open to all of the boaters and Fishers
however today SpaceX is closely
coordinating with the United States
Coast Guard to establish a safe Zone and
ensure Public Safety and up to t0 SpaceX
is in regular communication with the
Coast Guard to ensure there are no boats
in the area leading up to the launch now
fingers crossed that that does not
happen
now I'll throw it back to the folks at
Hawthorne as we get closer and closer to
that T-minus zero
we're just inside T minus nine minutes
and Counting we're listening on one of
the background Loops right now
flight director is talking about the
issue we've had on first stage working
the pressurization system decision right
now is that we are going to stop the
launch for today we're going to
transition the launch attempt to a wet
dress rehearsal so that means we're
going to continue with the countdown
sequence of events we'll continue
loading propellant finishing up here
shortly on the second stage we'll also
continue loading propellant onto the
first stage wrapping up a T minus three
minutes
we're also going to go through
pressurization steps other steps of the
countdown this will be a full validation
for the team but currently the plan
right now is we're waiting for final
word is that it I think at T minus 10
seconds we will finally stop the clock
and then recycle the countdown for today
now we're inside T minus eight minutes
and Counting
we're continuing to load propellant on
both the first and second stage you can
see the Starship second stage with the
heat shield tiles there
Terry Johns are open
you can see the condensation around the
first stage tank as we load liquid
methane the liquid oxygen into the large
super heavy first stage
and that propellant loading is
continuing until T minus three minutes
as a reminder Ellen there's our great
view looking up at the Raptor engines
the 33 engines
there's an outer ring of 20 engines and
then there's an inner set of 13 those
are the engines that can Gimbal and
adjust the course of the Starship
vehicle on the way up and of course the
first stage is it comes back down
towards the uh water landing in the Gulf
of Mexico
now when both stages they're loaded you
can see the condensation thrust on the
side of the first stage will have just
over 10 million pounds of liquid
propellant on board
it's RT minus seven minutes we're
continuing to count team is preparing
for the hold and scrub at T minus 10
seconds
now the good news is everything's been
going good we're just working that one
issue so we are continuing the count
team will get this as an excellent
opportunity to run the end to end of the
system
now in a launch in the next few minutes
the guidance system would be performing
its final alignment we will be doing
that this morning
the automated flight termination system
would be armed uh we won't need to arm
it today as we won't be flying and we'll
do final thrust vector control checkouts
what we call Wiggles of the Raptor
engines on the first and second stages
now normally in a countdown if we needed
to hold there's a view of the second
stage rafter engines
just above the first stage
now as I mentioned in a regular
countdown if we needed to hold that
would come at T minus 40 seconds that's
the point in the countdown where we can
pause the wait for final checkouts or
pressurization to complete now earlier
this morning we thought we might have to
hold it 40 seconds everything's looking
good except for the one pressurization
issue that the team is going to have to
troubleshoot after this morning
so we won't stop at 40 seconds right now
we'll continue all the way down to 10
seconds and then we'll go into a recycle
John you mentioned that we're going to
be jumping into a wet dress rehearsal
here and I've actually coming up T-minus
five minutes uh overall though okay it's
been a good day it's a little sad
listening to the flight director say
that we're gonna have to stop at 10
seconds but uh I guess that's for
everybody it gives us a real run through
of the launch vehicle yeah uh it's
unfortunate of course we wanted to see
fire today and lift off but that's okay
the point of the countdown is to allow
the teams uh to progress to that t-zero
time in a coordinated fashion and really
to
um unveil any issues prior to the
ignition sequence so
um the countdown did its job today uh it
allowed us to identify that press issue
and like John mentioned the teams are
going to to work through it and we're
going to basically call it off at T
minus 10 seconds but the integrated
launch teams and us we are going to
treat this as if it were still a launch
day we're going to do this what we now
call a wet stress rehearsal yeah and we
we've mentioned the term a couple of
times here we call it a wet dress
rehearsal because we are wetting the
propellant tanks we are loading
propellant into the vehicle we've talked
about the frost line a little bit here
that exercises the stage zero system uh
the ground system all of our
infrastructure that loads propellants
onto the pad that exercises our
procedures for the mission control teams
we're monitoring Telemetry on the
mission control consoles looking at the
pressures and the rates and the
temperatures and some of those things
look a little bit different when you're
getting up to the pre-flight uh
pressurization levels and full
propellant load so we're learning things
today about the integrated tasks that
are going to set us up for success in a
future attempt later on uh hopefully in
the next 48 hours or so
and and Kate like it's it's also worth
mentioning here we're still going to
take the count through to a pretty uh
around the T-minus 10 second Mark so
we're really going to exercise
everything that we would up until that
point in in the vehicle States and
ground procedures yeah it's like we said
before
um any data that we can collect today is
super helpful and that's exactly what
we're doing we are continuing to collect
this data and allow the teams to have uh
be better informed for the next attempt
um unfortunately due to the uh needing
to recycle the propellant we are looking
at a minimum of 48 hours until we are
able to attempt this flight test again
um so we're not quite sure what that
timing will be at the moment but we're
looking at a minimum of 48 minutes or
excuse me of 48 hours at this point in
time but exactly as you said things look
a little bit different on launch day and
we allowed the countdown to do its job
so you basically get to the point to
allow the teams to work through the
issues and we're going to continue like
we said before we're going to continue
all this down all the way to T minus 10
seconds and that will really allow the
teams to pretend like this is launch day
and continue and gather that data
yeah okay that's
on the one hand uh it's a little
Bittersweet on the other hand we watch
them go all the way through first stage
propellant load just now wrapping up the
second stage even the header tanks up
under the nose of the Starship that you
can see on the monitors uh actually that
all went very well today uh the weather
was excellent uh everything was looking
good sadly we just have the one issue uh
but that is letting the team continue to
count down
and we're going to continue with it here
until uh we get the clock hold at T
minus 10 seconds
yeah so for those of you that have just
joined us we're now at T minus one
minute and 30 seconds to what would have
been the launch of our Starship flight
test but unfortunately due to a stage
one issue we are going to utilize today
as a wet dress rehearsal instead we are
not going to attempt launch the teams
are basically saying that we're we're
scrubbing our launch attempt for today
and we are expecting a minimum of 48
hours in order to recycle
um so it's all good news though there's
nothing really to be sad about other
than we had hoped to be able to lift off
today but that's okay now one thing to
point out for folks when we do come back
when we clear this and we fly
one of the things you'll hear in the
last minute you won't be hearing us
because we'll be listening to the
countdown but at T minus 30 seconds
that's when the flight director would
give the final go for launch I'd love to
have hear that this morning but uh
something to look forward to absolutely
to look at is at T minus six seconds We
Begin lighting the engines up on your
monitor you can see there T-minus 40
seconds we did hit the 42nd whole point
and they are holding for a moment
in the end they will release that hold
will go to the last 30 seconds but yes
when we do get the day of launch the
last thing to look at is in the last six
seconds light the Raptor engines in
succession so unlike Falcon 9 we're
gonna have to do that a little longer
we're hearing right now the clock is
going to hold here at T minus 40 seconds
uh felt the super heavy and Starship are
looking good
so with that Kate uh it's been a
fast-paced morning you know we got
through it fairly quickly but uh at this
point we're gonna have to call it a
morning yeah that's right so for those
of you that have recently just joined us
we unfortunately had a hold on the
countdown today and that is going to
scrub our launcher tubs but we are
expecting a minimum of 48 hours in order
to recycle so be sure to keep an eye on
our social channels and we'll share
information as soon as it becomes
available until then stay safe and we'll
see you soon
foreign
[Music]